hello everyone welcome back to the final
day of the grand Chester's a Tata Steel
India Edition it's still the Boyd's
tournament dinkler inversus magnus
carlsen we've already seen two games
Magnus won the rapid game then being
retaliated in the blood section and this
is the second way this game wording has
the white pieces so ding is the only one
to beat Magnus in this tournament let's
see how they do in the second game and
going into the final day Magnus Carlsen
is still leading the tournament so
without further ado let's check out the
game as it is a very interesting one and
I would just like to say that well we
reviewed all of the emails you've sent
us regarding the chess manga so all of
you should have received a reply if not
we are still going through them so
expect them shortly if you still did not
receive your reply that being said let's
check out the game being witted the
white pieces opens with d4 and ok we
have e six by Magnus c4 and now f5 for
this this time Magnus goes for the well
for the Dutch defense with g3 biding
Knight to f6 Bishop to g2 and d5 so
everything perfectly normal here Knight
to f3 and Bishop to d6 still waiting to
declare the intentions of the C pawn and
here the most common move is just a
castle but the dingos for Bishop to f4
it seems like an odd move because it
allows well black the mess of White's
pawn structure and it's been played
maybe two times so far in talk to your
tournaments but this is what being
prepared for the affordable it's game
well she didn't know Magnus was gonna go
for the for the Dutch but obviously
something didn't care prepared for this
line Bishop captures on c4 Magnus of
course goes for the G captures on f4 and
now there is one game where Queen to d6
was played but here Magnus boldly
castles he doesn't mind the semi open G
file as well since the White's pawn
structure is all messed up you can play
g6 pretty much and you should be okay so
here Bing continues developing with
Knight c3 c 6 now strengthening in the
center and III with visas biding now
with ideas of finger throwing the light
square Bishop and Knight to e5 ding now
he worked hard for for the e5 square so
now he creates a very nice outpost for
his knight so Magnus goes Bishop to b7
and now rook the C 1 we have Knight B to
d7 you have you had to develop the
bishop first the guard the c6 pawn so
now you can develop the knight and I'd
be d7 and now Queen to a for putting
pressure on the c6 pawn Magnus
eliminates the monster night with Knight
captures F captures and now Knight to e4
and here instead of deciding to mess up
a black's pawn structure Singhal goes
and Knight to e2 he wants to transfer
this but this night over to f4 from
where he will threaten the e6 pawn but
not just yet so first after Knight to e4
we have C capture Sundy 5c capture Sun
d5 ending now Knight to e2 we have
looked the c8 by Magnus countering
White's rook on the C file and here rook
captures on c8 we have Queen captures on
c8 and now dink plays f3 which is a
really strong move as it gets rid of
crossings a centralized night and it
creates a very nice square for his
kingdom on an f2 and also the night
covers the C ones course you can
immediately bring the rook over to c1 we
have Bishop to c6 first attacking the
Queen well we should have mentioned
after Queen captures and C it you could
go after the pawn you don't have to play
a three right away but if you go after
the a 7 point Queen the c6 will now gain
a lot of activity for black so it's a
very unlikely that you will be able to
keep that pawn so after Queen c8 with F
3 like we said and now Bishop the c6
here grabbing the a7 point is not
possible if you grab the a7 point here
Bishop to b5 just wins the game for
black it's a really well it is a
terrible position because well Queen c2
fall by Queen e2 is the idea and even if
you eliminate one of the attackers you
still get Queen to c2 and now you don't
have all that much you cannot move the
knight because the bishop eggs if you
castle then you lose this you lose all
of these pawns
so not really much to do here if not
afford to go to guard the knight and the
bishop here then you get Queen to see
one check King f2 Queen D to check King
g3 captures with
and now it's just over if you go by
three you just pawn captures and attacks
the pinned piece if you go somewhere
else just captures and here you will
just get made it so not possible and of
course I think is not interested in that
he goes Queen not there he was Queen to
b4 and now comes Knight to g5 finally
Magnus gets the knight out of harm's way
we have King to d2 now instead of King
to have two saying that the King would
be much better here and also now the
King supports the rooks approach the c1
so the knight can now go to f4 to create
some chances against the east exponent
we have Queen d7 and now rook the c1 by
dink rook the c8 and now comes Knight to
f4
we have Knight to f7 the knight is well
it's a nice night but for the moment
it's not really doing all that much
which perhaps isn't the problem since
the Bishop isn't doing all that much but
the magnets tries to activate it we have
Knight to f7 you can go night d8 and
maybe from there you will add another
defender to the e6 pawn so nicely done
but now the bishop no longer needs the
Guardian three squares so here
Bishop the f1 now ding wants to go
Bishop to a6 to at least grab ahold of a
useful diagonal on the board will Knight
the d8 by Magnus now the knight guards
de-spawn the Queen can now also activate
and fish of the a6 attacking the rook
and here Bishop the b7 here ding repeats
a few times Bishop b5 attacks the Queen
Bishop c6 Coulson offers a trade and
Bishop to a6 attacking the rook here
Paulsen repeats a bishop to b7 but now
rook captures and c8 biting Bishop
captures Bishop captures Queen captures
and here Queen to e7 and this move Queen
to e7 pretty much paralyzes Magnus
completely he cannot move the knight or
the Queen since the e6 pawn falls and
it's just a very passive position to for
him he just has to basically wait and
see what the ding will do and he doesn't
have all that many opportunities to just
wait so here he basically has to decide
whether he wants to play an end game
against dink where he's down upon with
Knight to c6 now allowing Queen e6 check
captures characters
kingi sucking f7 so after the night
moves you would have this end game where
ding is up upon and it's a very strong
past epon so it's hard to say if you you
would be able to hold this
Magnus not interested in playing such a
passive game he plays h6 he tries to
keep everything together and makes an
escape route for his King but this is
even worse so feel free to pause the
video and try to find out why this is
even worse while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who are able to
do it
congratulations and the figuring out why
this is worse and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
well first we we should check out if
ideas like Knight h5 work yes you are
threatening mate but night of seven
blocks made and now you're still better
but you will have to work much harder
for your meal so the move you had to
find was Queen e8 check because this
really forces matters King to h7 and now
Knight to g6 and now you're threatening
Knight of fate check which will force
the king to the back rank and then you
will have some excellent and the nasty
discoveries so here at Magnus saw that
there is no way of preventing this he
went to Queen to c4 he wants to go Queen
before check and hopes to get a
perpetual but dink continues with his
plan Knight f8 check we have King to g8
and now Knight captures on e6 width
check we have King to h7 and now not
going after the piece there's no reason
to do that
so just Knight the f8 check once again
King to g8 non-id g6 check King - h7 and
now Knight to d7 the night still covers
the g6 and the g8 swears so Queen the g8
will be checkmate here Carlson has to
try to do some sort of a perpetual or
otherwise he's getting checkmated Queen
before check by Magnus with King to e2
now comes Queen captures on b2 with
check King f1 we have Queen the c1 by
Magnus King to g2 and now Queen to d2
with check and here ding just played
King to h3 and well it was after this
move unmoved 39 that Magnus Carlsen
resigned the game so Dean takes Magnus
down for the second time time in the
tournament and he still be only player
to beat Magnus well in in in the
tournament
so really really interesting stuff
Magnus takes ding down in that beautiful
beautiful Marshall welding plate the
Marshall attackable Magnus brought the
the novelty with Bishop captures on d5
but then thinks the ding takes there
both of the Blitz games so it takes non
Magnus symbol it's like he did in the
sinful cup so really a really a strong
blitz player this thing fellow but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
we're going to cover a few more games
from the from the last day of the Blitz
as well it already ended but we're not
gonna spoil anything for now we're gonna
discuss the the the live standings of
the raiding the the standings of the
tournament and and such things after the
last well game will be showing from this
tournament so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Stephen
green for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check through my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with a
few more games from the final day of the
attack Estill India blitz checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and of course
preparing the next big saga thank you
all I will season and have an excellent
rest every day